now are some of these men just really
collectors and they kind of hide
masquerading as uh sanitation workers
they do that or that some of these guys
get the stuff and sell it wow they have
businesses man really yeah they go to
like you know flea markets and [__] yeah
dude you have no idea man one dude in
Staten Island I hate to even give him
the shout out because he's a douchebag
but anyway yeah [__] him but yeah tell
me dude he you it was like sanidin son
on his roof leaving the garage some days
like he' take you know furniture this
that
everything and you would catch him at
the flea market ah and but dude listen
from what was told he had over a million
dollars from what he collected and sold
in a bank account
nuh-uh yep what are some other things
people would collect out there in the
trash anybody find anything really
unique over the years any bone structure
or anything like that listen you'd find
all kinds of stuff if you were looking
like I said like you didn't look though
I didn't have time for it like I said I
was running I want to get done I want to
be out of the street I don't want to
deal with people like I said the people
that don't pay attention to you they
drive into you right it's just risky hot
you know crabby days but this one time
I'm with my buddy you know Louie and
we're picking up this apartment building
and we open the gates and there's I
think it was six or seven Joker poker
machines and I'm like what the [__] is
this about video poker yeah like in the
bars you know they have those you know
yeah mom used to use our allowance in
them yeah and so I I worked at bars when
I was younger and I knew I'm like oh
yeah the money stashed underneath so we
opened them up there was nothing there
but I'm like you know what I remember
one of the bar owners having like a trap
door because sometimes the dollars you
know the $10 bills would just float in
and there was this little Tupperware in
it and it would float float and it fall
Perfect Right Down the slit so when I
saw that was still blocked off we
dragged them back to the garage we beat
the living piss out of these things with
with sledgehammers my boss walks in he's
like I'm not even going to ask what's up
right dude got 360 a piece $720 uh D and
they were the finest 10 and uh $20 1980
bills oh yeah they were like right out
the machine oh that's beautiful so yeah
that was one of my better ones but
listen you find things here and there I
always found something that you know
somebody was throwing out and I didn't
have to dig like it was next to the curb
um I found a moped once in Manhattan oh
yeah on the side of the you know right
on the side of a basket um um the corner
basket there and it was probably from
like a Chinese restaurant something like
that it was like locked in to turn left
so who's going to just keep driving in a
circle kids must have stole it and they
realized ah we can't use this so they
left it at the corner basket right so I
told my partner I'm going to take this
and as we're putting it like I said
there's a little trap door as I'm
putting it in there the uh the cops pull
up so we're like oh and this guy I'm
working with like damn oen you [__] me
all up now I'm going to get locked up
for this [__] right we're steing on a
[__] yeah stealing a moped from
somebody you know yeah from some Chinese
kid over here yeah like the guy's laying
there holding bags and N so he's like
they they just pulled up they were like
yo is it run I'm like I don't know I'm
going to see brought that [__] home
broke the uh steering collar and wound
up getting it started and I used to use
it to go down to the bodega down the
block and grab beers and [__] yeah so
that was a good find yeah that's a good
find yeah and I picked this dude up okay
you know probably 35 years on a job oh
he's been in there huh scraggly looking
guy big beard yeah come on kid you're
with me I'm like ah here we go oh come
on kid he calls you huh yeah so you know
what you're falling into there right
he's suddenly set in the stone you know
but yeah dude and everybody's like
looking at you wow cuz it's like you got
stuck with this guy oh really huh so
that's right away I'm like oh man all
right and like rule of THB first thing
they teach you is do not stand behind
the truck while the back of the truck is
cycling okay it this dude was looking
for everything in the truck really D we
he had all kinds of [__] in his beard oh
it was nasty and he didn't even care
like it was just like it was awful he
just back there just freaking catching
that high flying out he's hey you
looking for like and looking at me like
I'm not in there with him like I'm just
throwing it in to get rid of it dude I'm
not here to dig through it pulling out
like Spider-Man figures like you yeah
like crazy [__] oh yeah and would go
right in line with one of those kids
exactly exactly drive his at teacher
definitely that was his first job so
he's just back there just collecting
samples from the area huh oh hope you
enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this
one